imagine that you are not watching the
microcosmos right now instead imagine
you are living in the world as it
existed around 1 billion years ago and
you are the ancestor of this red algae
inside of you lies the DNA that you have
painstakingly acquired from your
ancestors it contains the instructions
for everything from the walls of your
cellular body to the components of your
organel that DNA has changed and ACC
culated through Randomness and selection
over billions of years and you are the
Masterpiece sculpted by that
process except you are about to lose a
quarter of your
[Music]
genes the history of red algae can be be
told in part through what they have
gained lost and given away over billions
of years it begins with a tale that is
familiar to many of us in the
microcosmos a long long long time ago a
ukar consumed a
cyanobacterium only to convert it into a
photosynthetic organel called a plastid
this process is known as endosymbiosis
and the organisms descended from that
ukar are now known as the arip plasta
which is made up of three groups green
algae and land plants are considered one
of those groups and then there's the
other group of algae called the gloop
phyes and then there are the red algae
called Roto like their archip plasted
counterparts red algae have chlorophyll
but they also possess other pigments
that help with photosynthesis and also
often turn them
red now when you hear the word algae
your mind might first conjure up images
of the green or archip plastids but red
algae is also widespread and influential
for starters if you eat Nori you are
actually eating red algae and red
algae's impact goes far beyond that as
we've just said red algae got their
photosynthetic plastids through
endosymbiosis but they also essentially
gave their plastids to others through
endosymbiosis many organisms like datom
can trace the origins of their
photosynthetic capabilities to ancestor
that consumed and converted a red algae
plastid into its own Machinery so red
algae have a legacy that spans far
beyond their own actions they show up
embedded in the ways that other
organisms are able to live in every bit
of food they derive from the Sun and the
chemical byproducts that sustain us all
but for all that red algae were able to
gain and share through endosymbiosis
their history is also marked by the
things they've lost like their
jeans one of the things that is really
striking about red algae is they don't
seem to have that many genes compared to
other ukar and more weirdly it seems
like they actually once did have more
genes they just lost them it's hard to
pick apart exactly how red algae lost
their genes and we can't say if it
happened very suddenly or if it was more
a gradual chipping away at their genomes
but based on the species they're able to
study today scientists think there were
at least two major phases of genome
reduction the first likely involved some
old lineage of red algae which likely
lost about 25% of their genes and in
this process they lost a key feature the
flagellum that threadlike structure that
many ukar use to drive themselves around
and there are some interesting
implications to losing the flagellum
especially for an aquatic organism like
red algae that would probably want to be
able to swim to locations that allow
them better access to light or to find
other algae to reproduce with but
perhaps that ancestral red algae was
living in conditions where the energy
required to make fella and operate them
just wasn't worth it maybe it just
thrived without the flagellum and there
was never a reason to keep it in that
case that ancestral red algae's loss
seems to have been Justified because red
algae are thriving without their fella
and without any number of other Pathways
that were lost with those genes and in
fact in the second phase another red
algae would reduce its genome by another
25% the descendants of that algae became
members of a group known as cyanop
Fatina the algae within this group and
particularly those from the class cyanop
a are particularly well studied because
they are extrem files meaning they're
found in environments that are
incredibly difficult to survive in heat
acid metal salt all things that we might
be able to tolerate in a very specific
range but these red ALG extremophiles
are not phased some can survive in
acidic environments whose pH values
range from 0 to four for context the
least painful end of that scale would be
like living in acid rain the most
painful like battery acid and as far as
temperature goes there are species that
can survive at 56° C or 132° F so the
reason we're not actually featuring any
cyanophytes is that they tend to be
found in places like volcanoes or hot
springs no our red algae are their Tamer
cousins found living along a Spanish
Beach but how could the cyanophytes have
survived such extreme conditions when
they have lost so much of their genome
surely those genes were useful for
something maybe but it turns out the
cyanides had a backup plan they could
get the genes they needed from their
neighbors there's a process scientists
have been unraveling over the past few
decades called horizontal Gene transfer
where genetic material gets moved from
one species to another and in general we
know it as a process that happens in
procario
driven by viruses or other vectors that
are able to transfer DNA from one
organism to another and procaryotes are
well suited to not only take genetic
material this way but also to quickly
embed those changes in their population
as they divide asexually eukaryotes
seemed unlikely to engage in horizontal
Gene transfer if only because we
couldn't really find examples of it but
when scientists studied the Genome of
cyanop CA algae they found hundreds of
genes in them that seemed to come from
bacteria and that seemed to help with
various functions like surviving high
temperatures or salty conditions and so
the same group of organisms that lost so
much of itself also found a way to gain
so much from others adopting the genes
of other organisms into their own way of
life and the most exciting thing is how
much there still is to learn we still
really don't know that much about how
horizontal Gene transfer shows up in the
history of ukar we don't know whether
red algae have gone through other major
phases of genome reduction we know
simply that Nature's boundaries are
porous and its identities are
[Music]
multifaceted thank you for coming on
this journey with us as we explore the
Unseen World that surrounds us the
people on your screen right now now they
are the people who allow us to spend so
much time Gathering beautiful footage
and also beautiful and wonderful and
bizarre stories of our world and then to
combine them for you to look at here on
Journey to the microcosmos if you would
like to be one of those people there's a
way to do that you just go to
patreon.com journeyto micro if you'd
like to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
[Music]
nearby